it started as a routine traffic stop and
ended in a fatal shooting of another
black man by police
twenty-year-old donte wright killed on
the streets of brooklyn center near
minneapolis
a tragic header says the police chief it
is my belief that the officer
had the intention to deploy their taser
but instead shot mr right
with a single bullet
this appears to me from what i viewed
and the officer's reaction in distress
immediately after
that this was an accidental discharge
this all coming as a former police
officer stands trial in minneapolis
for the murder of another black man
george floyd just a year ago
the mayor expressing his shock is such a
twist
we recognize that this is happening at a
time when
our community when all of america indeed
all of the
the world is watching
our community from the white house
president joe biden
also made clear his frustration you all
watched
i assume as i did the film which is
fairly the
body cam which is fairly
fairly graphic the question is
was it an accident was it intentional
that remains to be determined by
a full-blown investigation donte wright
called his mother as it was all
happening the call ended
when she dialed his number again his
girlfriend answered
and said he was dead in the driver's
seat like a minute later i called and
his girlfriend answered which was the
passenger in the car
and said that he'd been shot the
shooting acted
like tinder on an already volatile
situation hundreds took to the streets
to protest overnight
but some of those protests turned
violent it's been reported 20 local
businesses were looted
what's been described as a chemical
irritant was used to disperse the crowd
which was growing in numbers and
frustration police here guarding the
local station have had to face off
against angry protesters
they've brought in state troopers in the
national guard to bolster the numbers
they've even brought in concrete blocks
to secure the area
the local police chief believes that if
he's open and transparent
that might defuse some of the anger but
that might not be enough
i have four african-american boys so
every day
as a father raising boys in america how
do you think that makes me feel it's
terrifying
but it's not as shocking i mean it
wasn't shocked we this has been
happening for over 400 years
for us a state level investigation is
now underway
the local community wants answers
especially to the question
are things ever going to change alan
fisher al jazeera brooklyn centre
minnesota